So I actually do touch on this topic a little bit
in the interview that I did
with the new station that's gonna be airing tonight.
I didn't go super in depth into it because,
you know, it's nightly news in a public forum in a conservative state.
All right? I don't need Pitchfork showing up at my house.
But the idea that if you ban TikTok,
a social media platform,
you are somehow going to squash the revolutionary ideals
that are already being shared on it
is laughable. First of all,
every revolution in history pre internet era
took place with the organization of paper and pencil
and word of mouth.
Obviously, with social media, those ideas can spread quicker,
but they are not gonna stop being spread.
They will just be moved over to a different venue.
Look at all the right wingers when, like,
Twitter was having a goddamn meltdown.
They went on to like, freedom social.
You cannot stop ideas.
And we have a constitutional right to free speech
as well as free assembly for that reason.
Because all the patriots in the government should know that
revolution is the foundation on which our country was founded.
It's the American way.